[Applause]
[Music]
with the bow sweats well it's beautiful
Tony you gonna burn my truck I'm going
[__]
[Music]
if you found yourself living in fallouts
version of a post-apocalyptic society
there's a pretty high chance you'll end
up becoming a guinea pig for some
horrible social experiments and even if
you're one of the lucky ones ends up in
the control group you'll probably have
something awful happen to you anyway the
vaults were promoted as a refuge for
anyone who didn't fancy having their
eyes boiled at their sockets by the
lingering nuclear radiation but in
reality they are anything but designed
by volt tech to house as many humans as
they could hold and off and more each
volt was created to test and experiment
on its inhabitants in increasingly sick
and twisted ways we'll be looking at the
games as well as the non-canon sources
that's the fall our Bible and project
van Buuren who never released the
Fallout game to decide who had it worse
than a nightmarish post-apocalyptic
world of fallout so without further ado
let's check out the top 5 previous
vaults on the surface vault 68 and 69
which we're going to affectionately
title the boning vaults were one of the
best places to be both were named after
sex positions in the Kama Sutra with 68
a vault with 999 women and one man being
the position designed for female
pleasure and 69 a vault with nine
hundred ninety nine men and one woman
designed for male pleasure I highly
doubt that anyone in those vaults is
actually deriving any pleasure from the
situation but what else can you do with
vault number 69
I'm sure you could imagine what these
vaults quickly descended into and it
rhymes with 4G but not just any old 4G
one where one person gets torn apart by
a hungry Randy cohort dwellers if you've
ever watched the scene at the end of
perfume where lovely Ben Whishaw gets
torn apart by angry Parisian strangers
you can probably imagine the scene we're
talking about the purpose of vault 77
mostly seen in a Bethesda sponsored
webcomic made by the dudes behind Penny
Arcade was to test the sanity of one man
giving him nothing but food water and a
creative puppets as you might expect the
poor guy went from being relatively sane
to being a crazy Master of Puppets and
not in a cool Metallica way he starts
off by playing with the puppets to amuse
himself in the absence of human contact
but it's just a few short years until
the puppet start talking back does this
guy have it bad if he doesn't know
anything else at least he has company
even if it's all in his mind or in his
hands
vault 108 is a demonstration of how the
experiments could go very very wrong the
maintenance of this one was to study the
struggle for power in a vault with
various systems but in place to
encourage such a conflict however I
haven't instead was that everyone in the
vault decided to dabble in cloning
obviously tell me Chloe after the first
few turned violent due to an
imperfection in the process what did the
intrepid scientist do carry on of course
which unsurprisingly led to everyone
being murdered by Gary and his 54 clone
siblings for reasons known only to the
Gary's they can only communicate in
various tones of Gary like the gross
eugenics Pokemon game we never got well
you know what they say you say it best
when you say Gary young adult dystopian
fiction aside the idea of a
post-apocalyptic society made up
entirely of preteens is something that
makes most of us recoil in horror at the
thought of Diaries bad skin and
relationship drama on tumblr replacing
important things like politics and
health care and responsible drinking vol
29 s inhabitants were all under the age
of 15
raised by a super computer and a bunch
of robots and watched over by a
benevolent woman named Diana who was in
reality just a human brain connected to
another supercomputer it takes a village
to raise a child and it takes a lot of
creepy technology to raise a vault full
of them
we're imagining this one going down a
bit like Lord of the Flies but with more
radroaches and guns and fewer lessons on
the nature of innocence and morality
plants are a good way to pep up a
miserable environment yeah a cactus for
your desk put a banana plant in your
toilet give your friend a spore plan
there's nothing like plant life to make
you feel like things aren't so bad of
course the inhabitants of vault 22 that
didn't quite work out the vault was
filled with scientists dedicated to
their experiment
seeing if plants could sustain life
inside a vault now technically the
experiment was a success
I only say technically because the
people themselves turn into plants and
you know technically that fits the brief
because technically they're all still
running around what's a bit of extra
chlorophyll between friends now comes
the part of the show where we take a
look at the creations from the community
remember you can send in all your
wonderful creations using the hashtag GS
fallout on Twitter but let's take a look
at this week's creations first up we've
got the fallout 4 home remade by boudoir
banana fantastic name the sign has
actually recreated the opening scene of
the fallout 4 trailer inside Fallout New
Vegas and it's actually a close
representation of the actual fallout 4
home it's pretty impressive I don't know
if you can actually download this but
it'd be pretty interesting to run around
in first person in this new / old
neighborhood next up we have the fallout
4 garage diorama and this is adorable
someone has actually created a scene
from the fallout 4 garage tiny dog me
and all come on this on my shelf they
sent it to me
even cuter is the fallout 4 garage LEGO
creation by C MOX I'm not even this
created with normal Lego nvm making my
own custom fallout Lego excellent work
and this is terrifying this is a creepy
Todd Howard shrine this is something I
never thought I'd see in the world of
the internet but someone quote-unquote
found probably made a her terrifying
shrine to Todd Howard with it works it
just works spray painted again and again
and again terrifying but also quite
quite hilarious for just a quick
community wrap-up this week make sure
you send in your creations like I said
I've been your host Dave Jewett you can
find me on twitter at a regular dave and
as always stay safe out there wasteland
[Music]